i have been very fair to joe biden
during this afghanistan debacle i have
made a point not to attack him for
things that i would not have attacked
trump over i have made a point not to
blame joe biden in particular for the
broader mishandling of this war that
went on for 20 years
i have made a point to acknowledge that
any american withdrawal was going to be
messy okay i have not taken cheap
political shots even when basically
everyone else on the right has
so i think that i have some credibility
to point out now
joe biden has screwed this thing up
beyond
anyone's wildest imagination barack
obama
was very very correct when he said never
to underestimate joe's ability to f
things up
there are thousands of americans
currently stranded in afghanistan the
administration
is now refusing to guarantee
that it will get them out before america
fully leaves the country
by august 31st and there are americans
and afghan allies who remain there
will u.s troops stay until everyone is
out or will they leave so i'm not going
to comment on hypotheticals what i'm
going to do is stay focused on the task
at hand which is getting as many people
out as rapidly as possible and we will
take that day by day commit to bringing
back every american
can you
offer any guarantee to the americans and
afghan allies that if they remain there
past the end of the month u.s troops
will help them evacuate past the end of
the month
our our focus right now is uh undoing
the work at hand and on the task at hand
and that is day by day getting as many
american citizens as many siv applicants
as many members of a vulnerable
population who are eligible to be
evacuated to the airport and out on
planes
in other words no we won't guarantee it
don't worry though while the bidet
administration is stranding americans in
afghanistan our leaders are preparing to
open the door to tens of thousands of
afghan refugees
because this is not a serious
administration and this is not a serious
regime
and this is no longer a serious
civilization
in the time we have left before china
finally invades and puts an end to this
circus we will try to make sense of it
all i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from carol m who
says death to america hey that's biden's
slogan what a coincidence
that's that's what you're going to see
binarist 2024 death to america you know
when when things are feeling crazy when
the economy especially is on the ropes
when inflation is a major major concern
one way to hedge your investments would
be with acre gold i've been trying to
book a hotel because i'm going to go
visit some relatives soon and i don't
know if you've noticed this but hotel
prices are way up gas prices are way up
food is way up everything's way up why
is it way up because of inflation great
hedge on inflation is physical gold but
michael you say
physical gold's expensive i don't have
that kind of money lying around yes you
do hear me out if you have 30 you can
invest in physical gold michael
hold on hold on
acre has developed this ingenious way to
invest in physical gold for as little as
30 a month the way they do it you send
in your 30 a month
when your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars acre will discreetly
ship acre gold to your door they've got
a new hundred dollar a month
subscription if you want to up the ante
a little bit invest in a five gram gold
bar it's terrific stuff i really love
investing in physical precious metals
go to getacre gold.com knowles start
investing in physical gold today make
sure you go to this url because acres
giving away a gold bar to qualify for
the giveaway tweet or post why you
should be a recipient and mention at get
underscore acre
that is
getacregle.com knowles thank you acre
gold for supporting the show i tried to
be as fair as i possibly could i truly
believe not to toot my own horn okay i
think i was fairer to biden
on this thing than just about anyone
else but he is absolutely blowing it
it's outrageous even
even on the left-wing news channels when
the left-wing newscasters are trying to
flack for him even that isn't working
and the guests on those channels are
calling it like it is i'm curious to
hear your reaction
of this consequential speech by the
american president didn't run from it he
owned it he owned his decision he owned
the fact that as he put it the buck
stops with him
i hope he gets to hone their deaths too
i i don't i feel like i watched a
different speech than the rest of you
guys i was appalled there was such a
profound bold face lie in that speech
the idea that we planned for every
contingency i have been personally
trying to tell this administration since
it took office i've been trying to tell
our government for years that this was
coming we sent them plan after plan on
how to evacuate these people nobody
listened to us they didn't plan for the
evacuation of our afghan wartime allies
they're trying to conduct it now at the
11th hour the thing that they were most
concerned about was with the optics of a
chaotic evacuation well they got exactly
what they were most concerned of by
failing to do what was right when we
could have done it
so this uh
army veteran a guy who's working on on
these sorts of issues just right to
brian williams's face
i don't know what you're talking about
man i'm appalled and frankly there have
been people in the mainstream media even
on nbc and other left-wing outlets who
have said this is really bad stuff
it was weak sauce in the speech because
he avoided the main question and now
you're seeing
you're seeing this this madness of
straining thousands of americans there
meanwhile
it's it's not just the left that's
pushing to
before we get the americans out just try
to resettle all the afghan refugees it's
it's the republicans let's do it george
w bush george w bush obviously who began
the war in afghanistan is now now
demanding that the biden administration
take in as many refugees as possible he
says
the afghans now at greatest risk are the
ones who have been on the front
forefront of progress inside their
nation president biden has promised to
evacuate these afghans along with the
american citizens and our allies the
united states government has the legal
authority to cut the red tape for
refugees during urgent humanitarian
crises we have the responsibility and
the resources to secure safe passage for
them now without bureaucratic delay
so this is the sort of thing that you
always hear from
the left in america but also from the
liberal establishment right which is
you've got to take in
all of the world's refugees i'm not
denying by the way that people in
afghanistan are going to suffer under
the taliban make no mistake about i'm
not i'm not saying it's going to be rosy
for them
i'm just asking what is the limiting
principle
because
women suffer in many many countries on
earth
the people broadly suffer in many many
countries on earth there are a lot of
a lot of bad countries
spithall countries like president trump
might say are are we
morally obligated to take in all of
those people
even if you're just limiting it to
countries that we've had military
interventions in we've intervened
militarily in basically every country on
earth so are now are we obligated to
take in
all of the world's people who don't like
their societies
can we even do that obviously we cannot
do that
george w bush was modest compared to
some politicians in the united kingdom
rory stewart who's a british politician
he's actually now at yale's jackson
institute he went further he said that
that the west broadly has got to take in
millions of refugees he said i predict
that there will be millions of afghan
refugees but it will be over many years
and the us uk and all the nato allies
should share the burden between them
do you ever notice that that we're the
ones always expected to share the burden
why is that
why is it that there are there are many
there are some countries in the middle
east that do take in refugees and there
are many other countries that do not
take in refugees they take in barely any
refugees so the country's nearest to
these hot zones these zones with civil
war
very often they don't take in refugees
but then we fly these people to the
other side of the world to come to the
good old us of a
or to the united kingdom
or to europe you you heard macron
yesterday in france saying we have got
to resist the influx of migrants we just
can't take it our societies are already
on the brink of collapse
here in the united states just to remind
you of something
we have
violence in the streets we have people
burning down federal buildings we even
the left says we have insurrections left
and right i think i think the
insurrections are more on their side
than on our side but but regardless we
have insurrections in the country and
we haven't been able to conduct
a presidential election where the
overwhelming majority of americans
believe it was conducted freely and
fairly in a very long time
obviously the 2020 presidential election
remains contested including by the
candidate who is not the president right
now
but let's not forget the 2016 election
remains contested including by the
candidate who lost
everyone's saying that donald trump is
threatening democracy because he won't
accept the results of the election
hillary clinton still does not accept
the results of the 2016 election
and actually the the
disbelief in the legitimacy of that
election has been much more widespread
than this belief in the legitimacy of
the 2020 election
how about we get our own house in order
before we flood this country and others
with millions
of
immigrants who come from a totally
foreign land and a totally foreign
culture and do not
do not have a
blazing american civic spirit in the
spirit of democracy i mean isn't that
the problem in afghanistan is some
people naively thought that we could
democratize the country in 10 years and
it turns out that actually the process
of democratization takes at least oh i
don't know seven 800 years
so now we're just supposed to open the
floodgates why do we do this
why do we seem to be the only
civilization that ever takes the side
of
victims
we seem to intrinsically take the side
of victims there's actually
there's actually a very important answer
here i think it gets to the heart of our
culture i think it's what unifies our
experience on migration on
our own national history on tearing down
the monuments and frankly on
on
our popular culture as well
the west uniquely takes the side of the
victim
yesterday i i mentioned this there was
this clip of lizzo who's a sort of
famously hefty singer and she was
dancing around somewhat scantily clad
along with cardi b who was also scantily
clad and then she posted a video and she
was very upset and she said people are
making fun of me because of my weight
and
in the video she's claiming this is fat
phobia and
and so on the one hand we think well we
shouldn't be
exalting unhealthy lifestyles as though
they're wonderful and terrific and
everyone should should model themselves
after that but also we feel really bad
we don't want people to be mean to one
another so what what is the answer to
this what
why why is the the west uniquely so
focused on victimhood
unlike other countries on earth or other
civilizations on earth
the west uniquely takes the side of the
victim we've done this from our earliest
days just about
socrates
famously says in plato's gorgias he's
arguing with these rhetoricians and
socrates the philosopher says it is
better to be harmed than to commit harm
it is better now most people for most of
everywhere else in the world for most of
history have believed it's much better
to be able to harm other people than it
is to be harmed yourself it's much much
better to be the victor than to be the
victim
but socrates says no it is it is because
if you harm somebody unjustly you are
degrading yourself you're committing an
immorality it's much much worse
and you see this also with the the
animating story the animating fact of
our civilization
which is christ all throughout history
groups come together and they find a
scapegoat and they attack the scapegoat
and they commit human sacrifice and they
exile people
this is the
this is the the fact of human nature all
civilizations begin with a death right
you know romulus kills remus
we
it begins with cain kills abel
this is this is a fact of human nature
and the uh
the french writer
who died not that long ago rene gerard
points out that this is the way
societies work and christianity inverts
that
only in the bible and and to its fullest
extent in the new testament do you see
instead of instead of
everyone taking the side of the mob
against the the one victim you see god
taking the side of the victim
in the case of christianity that that's
what you have you have christ himself
who is the ultimate scapegoat the
ultimate victim who is killed by the mob
in this perfectly natural
way that humans interact with one
another and then he conquers that death
and so we i think
actually rene gerard goes on he thinks
this is where our victim culture comes
from he thinks this is where political
correctness comes from the idea that
victimhood carries currency
because
of of christianity now the the way that
we use victim culture today in political
correctness
is is a perversion of that right it's
it's uh you know even uh satan knows how
to quote the scripture to his own
devilish ends
but this is where it comes from this is
why you only see this kind of thing in
the west
and so
we're aware of that that's good i think
that's that's obviously one of the
wonderful features of our civilization
but we can take that to such an extreme
of self-destruction yes we want to take
in the orphan yes we want to take in the
refugee yes we want and we do that to to
a greater degree than anyone else on
earth ever in the history of the world
but you can't just fling the doors open
to everybody
because then you don't have a
civilization anymore then you don't have
a country and then you don't have the
ability to spread your charity which is
i think what a lot of these sort of
messianic liberals in america seem to
misunderstand
now speaking of lizzo speaking of women
who have struggled publicly with their
weight
speaking of
misunderstanding the real victims here
kirstie alley just made a great point
kirstie alley who is a terrific actress
she just tweeted out on this this
phenomenon of breastfeeding and chest
feeding and the whole transgender
craziness she said quote
breastfeeding is what women do women
also bottle feed men bottle feed too we
do not have to buckle to the insanity of
the minuscule minority of lunatics who
make us feel guilty for not sharing
their insanity
chest feeding human milk feeding wtf
stop it yes this as our public health
geniuses and our ruling class decides to
erase women from society they're now
redefining breastfeeding as chest
feeding they're not going to call it
breast milk they're going going to call
it human milk
because it's not only women who can
breed it can be men because some women
think that they're men and some men
think that they're women
and and the reason that we're going
along with this insanity this lunacy as
kirstie alley rightly calls it is
because
we have taken the good christian western
impulse to take the side of the victim
to stick up for the victim and not to
just scapegoat people
we have taken that to an insane
conclusion to deny reality itself
that's not a good idea nobody is going
to benefit
as we've been saying since this ideology
cropped up
no one is going to benefit
from denying reality and from indulging
people's crazy delusions and actually
and this is something we forget there
are going to be victims of this too
so when we take the side of the
marginalized of the man who thinks that
he's a woman
or people who have various other sexual
confusions
we are erasing women
we're racing women from sports right
we're erasing women from we're taking
away women's privacy in their bathrooms
and in their changing rooms we're
erasing women from our very
consciousness from society that's a bad
thing
when we take the side of the victim of
the economic migrants or the refugees or
the people who want to come from bad
countries to our good country that's a
wonderful thing
but if you if you do it to a limitless
degree there are going to be victims
here in the united states
they're going to be victims economically
they're going to be victims of crime
afghan migrants in particular commit
crime at very high rates that's just a
statistical fact
they're going to be victims of
cultural madness of political discord
even religious and racial discord that
happens sometimes
so you've got what we have to i think
channel our
wonderful impulse to take the side of
the victim we've got to
we can't be so narrow-minded about this
and only focus on one aspect of society
when you think politically you're
supposed to think about the public
you're supposed to think about everybody
speaking of things
that
uh women do very well that men are not
very well suited for
this is going to be politically
incorrect but i just i just have to say
it i know very even many so-called
conservatives don't want to talk about
this because they want to go along with
the liberal establishment and they don't
want to be called haters and meanies and
various phobes and everything but i have
to talk about it
pete buttige
is having a baby pete buddha judge and
his partner chaston are having a baby
now you might say michael
you know i took seventh grade biology
class and that doesn't
i don't think that's how it works that
doesn't make a whole lot of sense to me
well they're they're having a bit they
haven't explained how they're having a
baby
they just say quote for some time jason
and i have wanted to grow our family
we're overjoyed to share that we've
become parents
the process isn't done yet and we're
thankful for the love support and
respect for our privacy that has been
offered to us we can't wait to share
more soon
respect for our privacy is the key here
they're not going to say is this baby
being adopted is this baby being
concocted
in a in a laboratory you know is it is
this maybe being concocted in this very
clinical way where
where pete and chase and go and find a
woman and then basically just buy her
eggs and then go to another woman and
rent out her womb and then they just
create this baby for their own
edification who will be deprived
his own natural mother or or is the baby
being adopted well if the baby is being
adopted don't forget there are 32
couples in the united states for every
one baby that is being put up for
adoption so
the baby is being denied a household
where there's a mother and a father if
the baby is being adopted to
pete and jason now if if it weren't a
baby if this were someone who were older
and in the foster care system i think
the calculus might change here because
there are not 32 couples willing to
adopt everyone in the foster care system
there are very few actually and
single mothers for instance will
take in foster children often and so i
think i do think the calculus there
changes a little bit and i'm not going
to touch that topic
but in terms of
pete and jason
making a baby or adopting a baby or
somehow
we understand
why everyone is celebrating this we
unders because
pete and jason
are marginalized they're marginalized
because of their sexual desires because
they have these unusual sexual desires
and in a previous age this would have
opened them up to
much criticism and ostracism and today
that isn't so much the case but still
they have a natural desire to have a
baby but they don't have the biological
capacity to have a baby and so now this
is a way around them and because they
want that we want them to fulfill their
desires
and you're a meanie awful terrible
homophobic terrible bigot if you suggest
that that's not a wonderful thing
what about the baby
what about the baby
does a baby have the right
to his mother
if the baby's being made in a laboratory
for instance does a baby have the right
to his natural mother i look at my
little baby i see the way my little baby
interacts with my wife his mother
it's different it's just different than
the way the baby i i'm not saying i'm a
bad father but it's just different okay
because men and women are different
because mothers and fathers are
different and babies react differently
to them
because there's no such thing as chest
feeding in human milk it's breast milk
it's breastfeeding because there's a
difference here
even if it's an adoptive baby does the
baby have a right
to a mother and a father who are
different but michael you see some men
or men are just basically like in some
couples some men are just basically like
the women and some men are just like the
men yeah sure there are gender
stereotypes and roles and things and
people some of it is socially
constructed but there's just a
difference and so when we consider the
victim i'm not casting any aspersions on
pete and jason and all the other sort of
thing
i'm just asking what about the other
people here who deserve some
consideration like
the baby what about that what about
reality
what about the real distinctions between
the sexes and the natural family what
about those things we don't we're not
allowed to take that into consideration
even some prominent right-wingers were
celebrating this because they're afraid
to make these sorts of observations
but i think sometimes
our natural wonderful impulse to take
the side of the victim can get a little
bit perverted well we do this with
abortion too the the poor woman who
doesn't want to raise the baby and then
you think well what about the baby you
know that's another case of what i think
about the baby easy to forget about
we've got to when we think politically
we've got to think about
everybody
you know right now you can subscribe and
start listening to the morning wire on
apple podcast spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts and leave a five star
review if you like what you hear
you can also get 25 off a new daily wire
membership at dailywire.com subscribe
with code vip and be automatically
entered for a chance to win a trip for
two you and a guest to the daily wire
studios to see canvas live this deal
ends
today so act fast that's dailywire.com
subscribe get 25 off with code vip we'll
be right back with a lot more
we've got a whole lot of sexual
confusion in our society we've got chest
feeding
we've got babies drinking human milk
and we have on the economic front
a major she session and the only cure
for a she session you know
is a she covered just ask canadian prime
minister justin trudeau
it is exactly the example of the kinds
of things you need to do to counter the
she
the she session and turn it into a
she-covery
fact is the conservatives don't talk
about that in their lengthy platform
you're you're right justin the
conservatives
as far as i know they have never talked
about this she session and nor have they
talked about the she covered you got us
there
you got us there
so i i thought this was fake when i
first saw the clip i said no this must
be a deep fake or something like that no
he really said it and the point he's
making
is is even
more ridiculous than the phrases that
he's using
the point he's making is that the
economic recession
has disproportionately put women out of
work
so
the point he's making is that
ultimately we need
all the women
to be working
outside of the obviously women are going
to work in whatever they're doing
but we need the women to be working
outside of the home
this is another very radical idea that
was once
only pushed by the left once it was not
pushed by either the left or the right
then it was pushed by the left and then
even the right has adopted it too you
saw president trump talk about this he
said women's unemployment is at an
all-time low
i thought is that
is that a good thing is that necessarily
a good thing is that something we have
to celebrate we insist that all women go
out and work for the widget factory or
something like that
what if a woman wants to stay home what
if a woman wants to raise her family
keep a house and watch the kids
is that that's bad because then because
that would be the she session because
then the women's unemployment rate would
be high i mean they're not actually
unemployed they're doing the most
important work on earth around which all
the other work revolves but
that
is not
understood or recognized or valued in
our modern liberal society liberal not
just on the left but on the right as
well
why can't women do that you know there
was a famous debate between the american
feminist betty friedan and the french
feminist simone de beauvoir and betty
friedan said something and i think a lot
of people would agree with she said you
know if women want to go work that's
fine and if women want to stay home with
the kids that's fine too and simone
divorce said no
no no no
you cannot give women a choice because
if you give women a choice to stay home
and raise the kids they'll take it
and we can't have women taking that
choice because that is not conducive to
liberation
so you've got to force women to go to
work
and then you get into this strange sort
of economy now
where
men pay other women to raise their
children so that their wives can go work
for another man and get a paycheck so
that you can pay the babysitter to what
it does it gets a little bit strange
sometimes because women are not really
given the choice they're given sort of
the illusion of that choice but all of
the political forces
all of the cultural forces are telling
women don't if you stay home you're a
loser if you stay home you're wasting
your life and your education all
that great critical race theory that you
learned in school and all those crazy
gender theories
that's that's an illusion that's an
illusion of choice
pretty strange
pretty strange stuff kind of it's like
we're it's like we're misunderstood it's
like our best impulses are leading us to
misunderstand certain things
chest feeding human milk she session and
she covered this is not a serious
civilization
this is not a serious
civilization shivers shiva's realization
it's a civilization if you ask me
and china knows that so china is already
threatening the united states
china is doing this directly in response
to what happened in afghanistan
chinese state media tweets that from
what happened in afghanistan those in
taiwan should perceive that once a war
breaks out in the straits the island's
defense will collapse in hours and the
u.s military won't come to help
as a result taiwan will quickly
surrender
ouch i mean in in part i'm sure the
chinese state media are pushing this out
there right now not just to send a
message to taiwan but also to troll the
united states
and so that people like me will repeat
it on air but it worked because they're
making a point because the argument that
they're making here is probably true do
you really think that the american
people
want to go to war for taiwan
i don't
i don't think so
and it's not just the fault of the
selfish naive ignorant american people
it's the fault of the ruling class
what's the argument for going to war in
taiwan the argument is that it's a way
to contain china
sure taiwan's an independent country and
yeah we have a good relationship with
taiwan and yeah it's the right thing to
do but the national interest strategic
reason to go to war for taiwan
is to contain china which is now our
chief rival on the global stage
what was the argument for staying in
afghanistan i do think there was one
argument i'm not saying i agree with
this argument but it was the only one
that was even plausible the argument for
staying in afghanistan
was that it gives the united states a
base from which to check the ambitions
of china
from which to check the ambitions of
russia and from which to kill terrorists
now again i'm not sure that this was
sustainable very often you'll hear
people talk about how there haven't been
combat deaths in many many months in
afghanistan
we could have just held it with 2 500
troops forever i'm not convinced that
that's true the only reason we were able
to maintain that piece i think with so
few troops is that the taliban knew that
we were leaving i think if we reverse
that withdrawal probably there would be
another uptick in violence probably
you'd have to send more soldiers over
there as is happening right now so again
i'm not sure it's a strong tactical
argument but i get the strategy yeah we
need to do that to contain these other
world powers okay
but that's not the argument that the
ruling class made the argument that the
ruling class made was first that we need
to go get osama bin laden which i guess
eventually we did even though it took 10
years and we actually did it in pakistan
but that was the most plausible argument
they first then they they said we need
to spread freedom everywhere on earth
and if we if any government is not a
madisonian democracy anywhere in the
entire world then it poses an
existential threat to the united states
that was george w bush's second
inaugural was ridiculous it was insane
so that i didn't think that persuaded
anybody then it changed to we need to
nation build in afghanistan even though
initially we were not going to nation
build
that was never going to work
then it was we need to send women to
college or something
i don't even mean to downplay it i'm
sure it would be nice for the women to
be able to go to school but that we're
going to we're going to send americans
to go die overseas we're going to we're
going to spend two and a half trillion
dollars to improve the educational
outcomes of women in this one particular
country and not know other countries
that doesn't make a lot of sense then it
actually became lgbt rights you remember
this they raised the pride flag over
over the embassy in kabul you might love
the pride flag you might love lgbt
rights but does anybody really want to
go send thousands of americans to die
overseas and trillions of dollars
for the pride flag the
ride flag last i checked is not yet our
national flag we still have the stars
and stripes
pride flag might be our imperial flag
but it's not our not our national flag
so what was it what were we doing
none of those arguments were persuasive
and if they try the same arguments in
taiwan it's just not going to work
a serious civilization would be able to
ascertain its interest defend its own
interest
and
and be willing to sustain that for some
period of time
but i think it comes back to this victim
thing
because
we here
we don't like ourselves very much we
don't like america people are toppling
statues not just of the bad guys from
history but all the guys from history of
george washington of thomas jefferson of
of abraham lincoln for goodness sakes he
freed the slaves and they're toppling
his statues
we're being taught in our schools we're
teaching our children in civics classes
that america is a rotten terrible place
and you if you are an american and
especially if you're a white american
you're a terrible person so why would
anyone want to go project american power
overseas why would anyone want to even
defend america's own interests we don't
like ourselves
actually
this author i was mentioning earlier
rene gerard makes this point
discussing this victim mechanism that uh
jesus addresses the the
the preening sanctimonious people who
today say we are so much more moral than
the george washington than
abraham lincoln and the [ __ ] of
christopher columbus the horrible people
in our past we're so much more moral we
would never have killed the indians we
would never have enslaved people we
would never have conquered or purchased
lands we would never do that we're going
to build honors to all those conquered
peoples jesus does this in the gospels
of luke and matthew he says woe to you
scribes and pharisees woe to you you
hypocrites
who who put honors upon the prophets
that your fathers killed
you will kill them too you will do it
you are just as bad as them
woe to you
all these things will pass in this
generation
i i think that what is needed
what comes from all of our issues on
immigration on the economy on domestic
issues which are obviously very confused
on the way that different groups in
america relate to one another on our
imperial presence overseas
is a healthy dose of reality
just a healthy dose of reality i don't
think we need to say that immigration is
important and necessary and we need to
open the borders completely or
we need to completely close off
immigration forever it's a terrible
thing
what if we recognize that
permitting people into this country can
be a good thing but it has to be in
balance
what if we recognize that projecting
american power overseas is not always
wonderful or always terrible but is
sometimes a fine thing to do in measure
imbalance in moderation which is a
virtue what if we recognize that there
are many victims in the world and there
are many perpetrators of violence and
many victimizers and we need to
thinking politically take all of them
into account and balance these things
out when we're debating what to do in
afghanistan or what to do right here
at home
but it's hard for us to do that because
we're no longer a serious civilization
which is why we now have our teachers
the people who are supposed to be
educating our students
crying
on video on the internet
because their their students might
cough on them
if i die
who's going to take care of my children
and if i end up in the hospital how am i
going to pay those bills
and if i give covet to my students
or my own children and they die
how am i going to live with that
and i want you to ask any teacher
how they feel this year and i'm sure
that they will tell you that they have
never experienced anxiety like this
because it is like we are trying to
protect our students from a mass
shooting that we know is coming but
cannot do anything about except we can
do something about it it's just that not
everyone agrees that wearing a mask will
stop the onslaught of students and staff
who are likely to become sick and that
makes me sick
i think this lady is making a pretty
good argument for this she session she's
making a pretty good argument against
she covered because this lady should not
should not be working in public this
what she is not she is not
psychologically fit to do it if you're
crying over the prospect that one of
your students might cough on you
and might spread the germs that
statistically you have virtually
virtually no chance of facing serious
complications from a minuscule
infinitesimally small chance of facing
serious complications from and your
students have an even lower chance
you are not fit
to be certainly not to be teaching
anybody but probably not fit to even be
in public life this is this is a fragile
broken deluded person
and she says that first of all first of
all
children die of the flu
children face serious complications
sometimes from the flu this woman
assuming she's taught in the years
before kovid
has gone to school during flu season
without a mask
without
bottles of purell everywhere the unholy
water of our new religion our religion
of public health
she she's done that and it's fine and
she hasn't she hasn't been waking up in
a cold sweat
under the the horrible thought that she
might have given the flu to her student
or vice versa
now
with the coronavirus which is around us
she says she can't the thought that you
would go to school without a mask it's
terrible because if we just wear a mask
then the virus won't spread except we
found out the virus spreads even with
the mask
the virus
spreads even with the vaccine
the virus spread it's a virus that's
what happens
we had very serious lockdowns in this
country the virus continued to spread
actually
beyond our cut i should give this lady a
break because she's not even the
kookiest on this topic
if you go down under or if you go to the
little island right next to the land
down under if you go to new zealand
that nation is going into a full
country-wide lockdown
because of covid because of a surge
do you know how many people
got coveted
in this surge what do you think it was
do you think it was
a hundred thousand people
ten thousand
one thousand one hundred
one person
a single case of covid was confirmed in
new zealand they're locking down the
entire country
new zealand prime minister jacinda adern
has authorized the nationwide lockdown
after a single case of covid19 was
confirmed in auckland
telling citizens
not only that they had to
stop going about their normal business
but they actually had to stop
speaking to their neighbors
so a 58 year old man tested positive for
the virus he didn't die
no reports that he's gotten even
particularly sick but he just tested
positive
this is now triggering week-long
lockdowns in auckland
and cora mandel
coastal town that he had visited
it's triggered a three-day lockdown for
the entire nation
this will be a level four lockdown
where schools offices and businesses are
forced to close with the exception of
essential services
this is not a serious civilization
know what i noticed of all the horrific
videos coming out of afghanistan
the one thing i noticed is there's not a
ton of
masking going on there's masking of the
women i suppose there's full burqas for
the women but for
the men who are taking over the country
right now the men who are trying to
escape
they're not concerned really about the
mask or
social distancing or the rapid spread of
covid or anything like that
because they're focused on important
things they're focused on things that
matter they're focused on things that
will shape
souls and state
they're focused on
adult matters and we here in our
civilization
are
terrified of the cough and living our
lives in fear and crying because
students might cough on us
and wringing our hands over whether to
call it chest feeding breastfeeding
or or anything
else i'm sure there will be some new
politically correct terms soon enough
be ready
to mask up for many more months
this is go i know you thought it was 15
days i know you thought maybe we've
we've reached peak craziness haven't we
we haven't according to the ap the
associated press
quote if you're flying on a plane or
taking a train be ready to keep wearing
that face mask for a few more months
the transportation security
administration says it will extend the
face mask rule on public transport
until january 18th
january just a few more months
just a few more months we promise
just a few more
huh
how many more months
just a few more days just a couple more
weeks to slow the spread
obviously you can't believe any of this
these people have no credibility but it
doesn't matter because they wield power
in whatever capricious lunatic ways that
they want speaking of the ap not just
the associated press but the advanced
placement course
there's this is a great leak just came
out from an ap
government practice exam this is an exam
that high school students take if
they're in the really special smart
classes distributed by the college board
it asks these sorts of questions these
are the questions this is not just a
lesson about your opinion this is not a
lesson about different views of a of a
political matter this is what you were
being taught is the correct answer or
the incorrect answer to get a good grade
so you can get into a good college so
that you can advance in this society
here's the question based on the
infographic which of the following
claims would an opponent of state voter
id laws most likely make
they give four answers the correct
answer is voter id laws are likely to
decrease turnout among african-american
voters because they are less likely to
have government-issued ids
so the question is what would an
opponent of voter id hypothetically say
based on this infographic that we're
giving you here
and the answer is that they're racist
and that people who are pushing these
laws are racist
there's no
there's no flip side to that it's not as
though the college board is saying okay
and now what would the other no it's
just here's the thing here's the
question voter id laws
if you want to get the correct answer on
this exam is it racist yes it is racist
here we go thank you next question based
on the infographic which of the
following strategies would a group
seeking to increase voter turnout likely
pursue
and the correct answer is
they would lobby state legislatures to
overturn voter id legislation
this
is this is the way that our students are
being educated
and i know that conservatives for at
least a decade or two now have thought
no no we shouldn't do that we shouldn't
have students being indoctrinated in the
leftist point of view but we shouldn't
have them being indoctrinated in
conservative views either we just need a
perfectly neutral point of view
there is no neutral
there is no neutral there's no there's
never been
neutral in education
there are
true things and false things and good
things and bad things and right things
and wrong things
and conservatives are either going to
develop the cajones i don't know what
the new gender-neutral term for that is
to stand by
the true and the good and the beautiful
and the right and the just or
we're just going to see all of that
moral ground to
the left
there is a group in minnesota of 162
school principals and assistant
principals that just issued a public
letter for quote de-centering whiteness
and dismantling practices that reinforce
white academic superiority
while claiming that their efforts mean
that they're uh
they're making a sacrifice for their
children
you see white children
in a way they're the victims of this
because they don't even know how racist
and bigoted and terrible they are and
they don't even know the sort of
oppression that they're they're
foisting upon the world
so what we need to do is tell them that
it's bad to be white and it's bad if
they were born white and we've got to
de-center whiteness and dismantle
whiteness or whatever that means in the
classroom
we're focused right now on the religious
fanatics of the taliban
and the theocracy
that they are instituting in afghanistan
no doubt they're doing that
these people
here these american leftists
are just as religious as the taliban
they are just
as religious and they are just as dead
set as instituting a theocracy in this
country a theocracy that makes lots of
kooky claims about the metaphysical
spiritual moral world including the idea
that you your body has nothing to do
with who you are and if you're a man who
thinks he's a woman you actually really
are a woman including the idea that race
connotes certain spiritual
characteristics and if you're white
spiritually you are you are lesser than
other people including the idea that
that victimhood carries currency
not when the victim is innocent not when
the mob is wrong but just in all cases
at all times such that you must destroy
your very civilization that it is good
and right to do that that is a pretty
crazy theocracy that we're living in
folks and maybe before we take a look
overseas and try to solve everyone
else's problems
maybe we ought to figure out how to
solve our own problems here i'm michael
knowles is the michael knowles shall see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bora our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright dailywire 2021. on the matte
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show